Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to three awesome games
I've got some weird ones here not too bizarre. Thankfully not bizarre enough to be a three bizarre games, but should be pretty fun
So let's check them out. Okay. Well, whoa, welcome to how to be a tree
You are a tree don't worry being a tree is easy. Alright
how to be a tree
Do nothing
Tree life sure is nice, huh?
Sometimes I envy you trees. What are you a floating? Eyeball? I hope you don't mind me staying here
I'm just taking in your majesty on this fine day. I mean, that's pretty much what everybody does to me
They just take in my majesty. Oh god. This isn't even I'm offline. Well good thing that doesn't matter
Oh, that's not even fullscreen. How do I make it fullscreen? Well, whatever. Alright I guess I just got to do this
I don't know what this guy's talking about. He's jabbering on about something. Oh
I don't know what oh god, okay
What happened I don't understand alright the devotee oh
Oh, you are a tree Oh
God oh hey. What are you doing? Oh, oh my
Tree
Just press R. And let's forget this ever happened. No, I'm a tree bitch you get out of my way. I'm a fucking tree
Okay, alright, oh my god, how are you doing this, you know, I'm not a hundred percent sure
So I think this is the mist of whoa
Yeah, the mystery is just up in the air. Hi, and so you disregarded the eyes imposed ideals and bounced into a curious?
Portal press R. Or I'll tell on you. Ah
Alright sure. It's a little trippy a little trippy little little trippy. Alright. Oh god. No. Oh God
Yeah parently we good god the truck
Is it
Alright sure. We're gonna go with a whole lot of sure. Look, I don't know exactly how to do locomotion here
So just bear with me. Okay. This is not obviously not correct
No, that's not correct either. Wait. Okay so up does that
Right turns me that way, which goes forward?
somehow
Compress and crawl. Oh, oh
Okay Wow Wow here I go
Whee oh
Boy, this is this is messed up man
straighten and then shrink and quickly expand
Okay, straighten, okay straighten or run free and embrace chaos. Okay. Oh
That works
Hey, that's great. Wait, I see good god, the music is so grating
This is just hey, you got the triangle of power buddy. Thank you. Okay, here we go. Here we are
This is a messed up game seek your ancestors child. I
Am so confused
I think it was just the most confused I've ever been in my life. Okay, the open world. Oh wow
Venture forth and return to fractal space with 13 of your brethren. All right
But do not forget yourself on your journey
Remember you are a fractal. All right after all you cannot be a tree. Can you?
You do not even have roots. Okay
Whatever you say buddy Wow. I don't know what this is, but it doesn't seem to be deadly seems like the the Giants - oh
shit
a
Little warm things
Pleasant
That's not pleasant at all. Okay
all right, so I somehow
Got a straighten out. There we go. Okay. We're just go wiggle worm. Oh
No, okay. Hang on
We're gonna wiggle worm our way
into
This little thing
No, god, damn it. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, not the hole. Okay. Dive headfirst. Yeah. Yeah
Yeah, there we go. I don't know where this is going, but I got a bad feeling about oh shit. Oh
Okay, well I'm dead alright, well that was that was horrible okay in the hole
in the hole
Straighten out. There we go. Slide. That's that's weird. Okay, I got up. No
No my roots, I mean I didn't even get my fractal friends I guess
That's
Control roots. I don't control my roots. Would you mind moving your roots? Oh, is that a worm? Oh my god
I hate that. Thank you
You're what?
All right, god, I'm gaudy oh this is horrible horrible horrible horrible horrible horrible horrible
Everything's horrible horrible horrible horrible horrible
Horrible horrible I'm through I guess I didn't want to go through but I'm through
Horrible mark you want up? All right. Oh, I don't get up apparently
Okay, Wow. All right this the worst thing I've ever seen in my life. There we go. We're free
All right, get out of my face shut up you're not a tree I'm a tree
Okay, I gotta get in this hole but not going the exit to get
Stupid thing
Okay. Yeah, I wanted to dive who would have been great
If I didn't like a somersault dive into the hole, but I didn't so I know why would you do that?
You control like a piece of spaghetti
this is much more difficult than it seems it doesn't exactly control the way you'd expect a
Limp noodle to control oddly enough you'd think it would but it don't there we go. This is gonna get in there
There we go. All right. I did I get it. I got it. Okay. I got it. All right, whatever
okay, so I need to
Expand rapidly. Nope, I did it
Okay checkpoint apparently so guys awaits laps around it. So horrible. It's so horrible
I got it with my
Roots, I can't penetrate that. There we go. Now, let's no let's just
Get in the hole
Great not no god, damn you. Oh
Fucking job
Geez, ohms. I'm going right
It's like fucking Bennett 40
I'm not gonna be able to get out of this. Well there I'm dead. Okay, great. Oh, I'm alive great
There we go, I'm in Oh
Off off okay, I shouldn't be here but here I am apparently, ah, yeah, I can't move forward. That would be okay. Well
Take some of my off. Well, there was no point in going in there was there I don't know man. Okay roots
Yeah, Wow. Yeah, ow. Oh there was a point in going. Oh, I got it. Anyway, whatever cuz it doesn't matter
There we go. There we go. I'm embracing chaos
chaos
No, that's wait. No, but I didn't get everything. Oh, I probably got to go through the
Little wet. It's fine. Fine. Didn't need those anyway
Straighten out. There we go. Okay Oh
No
Hahaha, I am the best. Okay, and then
Flat as can be
Do not saw me in three
There it is. I need that. No, I need that. No, I need that. There we go. I got it. Okay good
Can I go to this thing now? Can I get out please? Just let me out. Just let me out No, let me out, please
There we go, oh god this is just the weirdest game I've ever played
Well, maybe not the weirdest but this is just bizarre. This makes it in the land of saws. Oh boy. I
Can't wait to go to the land of saws. Hey
Grandpappy. Why will you take me to Saul and I always done wanted to go
very real
There we go, yeah, I got it okay. I just need to jump up embrace chaos chaos control
No
There we go got it, ow
Fuck well didn't get a checkpoint. So I guess dumb. Oh wait, I already got those nevermind. I guess I did get a checkpoint. Ow
Alright just go go man. No go forward come good. No, don't do it. You know my
This game sucks this game
Just lay flat Oh Rick. Okay, just lay flat flat
Alright now lay flat
Perfect. Don't move a muscle
I don't even know if you have muscles frankly. I hope you don't embrace chaos. Ow. Chaos control. Can't checkpoint
Alright now go up. No, no, no god. Damn it. Okay, embrace chaos control
This is a terrible checkpoint. Why would anybody want this checkpoint?
Kalman him. Oh wait, I got it. Embrace chaos, I guess Oh No!
Okay, flatten, there we go flatten
Perfect
Perfect. We dunzo baby
And so you fell into the factory in shoot and we're transform what huh. I'm a book now. That's the endgame I guess
You're a book now
What oh, oh
Okay, we
I'm embracing kale. So no, I don't get it. But I did it guys. Yeah, there are different paths
I get that which is what I'm doing. I need to fix this
I'll freeze you until we can get you right no, no, no, don't worry about freezing me
No, no, no freeze. Ray engaged. Okay, whatever miss me
Hey, whoa. Hey, whoa Oh God, and so goes the life of a tree. Ah
captured Oh
All right, I guess I can't expand. Oh, I don't want to keep playing this. I don't want to keep going on this one
I think I'm good. I think I think the life of a tree has been properly explored and my eyes are probably scarred
So I think I'm good. Okay, that one was a success a
Rousing success. We're gonna dig
Deep okay. This is a game about my favorite part of
Something it's like my my favorite home beach body trainer
Sean T. Always tells me get my knees up keep my core tight and dig deep. That's what he says
That's like his three things Sean. T always tells me get my knees up above the waist
Well, I keep my core tight no matter what I do and dig deep
Those are the those are the three things that always have to be done
Wow, very impressive. Oh
Okay, all right, right
Wow, oh
Wow
This is literally my favorite part of minecraft was just digging holes in the ground
I'm glad that they found a game that really does tie in to just that aspect of the game. This is a hospital
ah, no don't
This is okay. There's this is pretty cool. I'm down with this. Oh shit, you're dead. All right. Well, sorry about that
cool
All right. I'm down for this press fast. But I want to what are we gonna press fast? Oh, that's dumb
Okay, oh hey buddy, how you doing, uh
Okay, no, that's that's pretty intuitive I thought it was gonna be like a press to sprint kind of thing
That's not too bad. I got I do got a spam it but it's okay. Ah
Oh
Shit. Oh
Hey, no, don't follow me. Get blown. Oh shit. Oh, he's dead. Not sad, okay
Is that invulnerability or something probably oh shit. Oh
Okay, thank you this is not bad it's interesting it's a different concept than what I'm used to but not bad
Wow, wow wow
Wow, it's quite satisfying I gotta admit. This would probably be a good mobile game. You know what I mean? What did I just do?
Exploded you're ready for adventure Oh am I I thought I was currently in Advent. Oh, here we go
I guess we're going now. Okay. I thought that was just a tutorial stuff baby stuff
This is this is top tier gameplay right here. Oh
No
My body
How am I expecting to get out of this hole that just goes down into in definite forever
Because that seems to be a problem for this, okay? Oh wait, I got something here. What do I have?
dig deep reward
claim, oh
It is a mobile game
This is available on it. I didn't think it was a mobile game
Okay, it's a bit of a mobile game but not bad okay, I mean, it's fun I got no problem with it so long
It's not just a money-grubbing mobile game. Then we got no problems. Ah
No, ah, that was a bad move
All right. Well, I can't say that. I'm good at this game yet. Well, I can't say that
I'm ever gonna get good at this game. Good thing
I got this new keyboard with mechanical switches, even though I hate mechanical keyboards, but I did get it
Why cuz I'm an idiot
Boom kaboom. Wait. No. I thought that was gonna go a bit farther than it did. Okay swoosh
You know, I don't like a mechanical keyboard. It's as I needed two keyboards and one of them's wireless and one of them's not no
Well, that's hardly fair. Okay. What is this? Disposable boost? I don't know. He's sure. Yeah, okay. All right, you have one
Okay, I don't know what that means but I'm gonna keep going collect ten mega gold pieces fall on an alien and crush it
Why are aliens under the ground am I the only one that's confused by that?
I just don't see how they got under the ground
I guess it's kind of like how the story behind those Gears of War like isn't that the story behind Gears of War like
That it's kind of underground aliens, or are they aliens? I don't know. I've never actually played the games
I was played Gears of War in college with
One of the people who lived in my my dorm hall. He would invite me over to play
I forget his name
But he invited me over to play but we would only ever play like multiplayer
Competitive matches because that's all he wanted to do and I didn't know how to play the game
So I was like dude. Can you explain to me at least like what I'm doing a like?
I'm just dying a bunch to you. Who's the only other person playing this game and like he just would not
Yeah, he just wouldn't explain how the game was played
so we just kill me over and over and over again and he'd kill me in the most annoying ways possible because he would like
He'd shoot me I get knocked down and there's like a point where you can get back up and he would just stand over me
With like a shotgun or something wait for me to get back up
And in the meantime, I can't do anything he would wait for me to get back up and then kill me straight up
Like and he was just shoot me right in the head my head would blow up. I'd be dead horribly dead
and then just that was it and that was all we did and that lasted for about thirty minutes and I was like dude this
Is not fun for me, Lou whatever man
larry's whatever and just I just remember that so
distinctly as being the douchiest way someone could ever invite you to play a game just
Kill you and I'm sure that everybody has some kind of experience with something like oh no, I forgot about Myka boomer
No, he wasn't even my friend. No, he was not my friend
He was just someone who lived in the same dorm hall and I was bored and I was just like yeah sure
We'll uh, we'll play. Yeah, I've never played by I saw the trailer for that game looks cool
You know, I thought that maybe had a co-op campaign or something. This is like, nope
He just wanted to kill me a lot over and over again just said use space. What was it supposed to be?
I can't use space anymore. I guess it's not a thing. Maybe it's the thing only the beginning
Let me blow up again real quick and I'ma blow up or die because I want to use this disposable boosts unit
Whatever that is go for it. Use it boost there. Oh
That's nice. Oh, that's real. Nice. Oh, that's nice
I don't know what the benefit of gold versus mega gold is. Those are worth one apiece Oh
Fifty, oh that's totally worth it. That's way better. It's it beep more
It'd be better to go after those versus anything in this game. Okay. All right. Well, you live and learn
Davi, oh, oh I can still get it
Okay, I miss that but whatever. Okay, I think I get the gist of this game
I'm not really too interested in playing this to completion. But let's just see how far I go with this one run of it and
Deal from there. Okay. Now this is a trick, but I'm not chased by aliens. So it's not that big of it
No, no, no. No. Okay. It's not that big of a trick
I mean, this is the kind of game that's like it's kind of perfect mobile game because it's just it's just a little bit ridiculous
Concept but just repetitive enough gameplay. That's slightly addictive. It's not bad
I got no complaints about this game, but it's not exactly the kind of game that really sparks my interest. Hey, that's nice. Oh
Wow, hey bonus, just because I usually like either a story if I'm wasting my time
Or at least the feeling of a story something like that
But right now this one's a Lulu
shit
No, no
How was I supposed to be able to get out of that one? I guess I could have blown up or whatever
All right, so I think we get that game. That's pretty good
We could have been playing together in Gears of War
So that guy was just a dick and he just want to blow my head off. All right, so this one's called
Project blockchain Z and I don't know if this is like some
future where
cryptocurrency took over the world and they just absolutely destroyed everything and
It just created zombie virus for blockchain stuff if that's even possible. Oh
Oh
Yeah. Oh
That music though. Oh, that's nice. Let's just go for it. I get random challenge soldier rookie Ranger other soldier
That what you were saying right now the horde of zombies are coming as the captain you must keep the bunker in safe
Yeah
That's not a good start find out the survivors across the city destroy the zombies and fight the Raiders resist until the reef or sment
Reinforcements arrive. All right, then project blockchain Z is a third-person shooter game with RPG and tactical view mechanics
Get ready to defend the bunker
Whoa, what happened?
'J' to see controls next to consume you blue elements or buttons you can interact with I'm a button
Okay was to move mouse wheel to zoom in and out left mouse button move them across with the right
What whoa
What the hell oh
This is battle. Oh
Okay Wow, this is not gonna
I'm not gonna remember all these but okay the orders are for all your troops
why to send quick orders build things with the Z key why this
Okay, that's a lot to take in. Okay siren. Sure
They're right. Hello? Hi buds. Hey, come on over here. Did I press right button? Okay formation line
Find cover
I don't think that was cover
I've already four low bullet time. Okay, Z build a barricade
This is kind of cool, I mean if it actually works out, I don't know if it's gonna work out
But if it does, that's cool. Alright explosive barrel one there
One there ammo box
I'm
Parently all done
Right there, I guess and then mine's deployer. Sure. Alright mines. There we go. Oh
Maybe you guys should get away from that
Take oh you don't take cover then. Okay, let me go most tactical. There we go. Okay you
Go there. Okay, so you yeah
Just there we okay. All right. Okay. All right, that's good. I guess cool. Let's let's do it then
Well, this is inaccurate
Okay, I'm concerned about that big one, I don't know if I should what's dead never mind that is handy with the distraction Oh
Go Go guys, you don't need to be turned what your legs
A little concerned about your leg your legs there, but are that's fine. Ah
I
Can see that this is still early in development
With like the non finished models, no textures all that stuff. They're just trying to get the gameplay there
That's not bad. Like this isn't bad. It needs some more refinement with the the gunplay Oh God world map tutorial
I don't know. What what the hell is that the space bead bunker?
Gee, I'm not gonna remember these Manny's bunker in bunker. You can train troops improve technology bite coins II Oh,
White coin that's funny
That's really funny if you see this icon hover the mouse to get more info
Sambi hatches zombies raider storage raiders
Survivors, bah, don't let the survivors count reached zero, okay
Right, uh-huh
Yep
Yeppers peppers, you got it. What do I do? Oh shit. Wait. No. What are you doing? Who's doing that?
I don't know what I'm doing wait now Jake controls, uh
Hmm, okay. Oops. Oh
Yeah, I do oh
Yeah, I do. Oh, you know where am I? I don't know where I am. Okay, Oh put that there put that
There put this here put a barricade
Here gonna put this there and this there all right, whatever let's just go for it. It wasn't exactly difficult. So
Hopefully it's not gonna be difficult either. Hey, you guys want to point in the right direction?
Maybe I'm not pointing the right direction. Is that zombies? Oh shit. Oh, you guys are right. Okay. Oh shit
Okay, Oh, let's go mano-a-mano in this Hey, look, I'm breathing. You can see my breath
Hey, all right you losers you nerds
What are the weapons we got here pistol?
Well, though the pistol is better than the machine gun was oh
Sweet what about shoddy
Brad I love it
brains, really
Really? These guys are brains hungry for brains. You guys want some brains t-posing over there?
This is surprisingly well-made for a free game and just to demo at that
It's the present really they spawn out a huge. Okay, they respond they spot out of huge
Tombstones perfect, but you see little lesson about game development
See now that they've got like the gameplay and everything is placeholder
All they have to do is just start refining the gameplay down and then replace everything with not placeholder stuff
slowly start to flesh it out and
Then that's it
you can actually work out pretty well because a lot of games they try to make it look good first and that's like a big
Mistake looking good is not important in the beginning phases of making a game. It just needs to play
Well like that is only the thing that you need
Let's go fight some
Raiders maybe can only go fast fast like super fast. Can you go here? Why aren't you going there? All right
Never mind. I guess we can't fight the Raiders
Yeah, let's go. You know, I'm not even gonna we're just gonna go for it. Yeah, but no, it's really cool
Like I mean the city looks terrible with all its pure white aspects of it
It's not even stylized like superhot but you know, it's it's just nice. Hey, how you doing peek-a-boo
Peek-a-boo? peek-a-boo. Where's these?
Big old tombstones there. They is man. I don't even need to do anything. My guys just kill them all anyway
jeez, there is a bit too much like
Recoil when I shoot it's just too jarring when the camera shakes like stuff up. It's like I'm gonna punch to the neck
Hey, hey
Guys, why won't you watch my back?
There we go easy peasy, hey survive ease, I don't know if there's a good thing to go for here
But I'm gonna go there doesn't seem to want to let me go to the Raiders camps, huh?
What a group of enemies are attacking me. Okay? All right, let's go for it
Where are they attacking from?
Wonder if these guys are actually gonna be any tougher because like in any zombie game the real threat is other people not the zombies
Themselves. All right, three two, one contact
1-800 Contacts?
Oh hello! Woah my god! Holy crap
That's too many. Alright
It says I have grenades but ... oh I do
Okay.
That probably did good
Alright, well he's dead. I need some heals
ow. Who did that?
Ow Jesus how much you just kill him? Okay
Let me get my shotgun. I just want to pop out from corners and just blast people cuz otherwise I'm gonna die
No, okay. Never mind. They are. Bullets move fast apparently, oh, but bullets move slow
if I do this
Smart, I'm smart. Yeah shit wait, maybe not that smart. I'm gonna die. I don't know how to oh
There we go
Healing who knew it could be that easy Oh like a dream
Ow
Ow, Ow, Ow. Ow
It's like I'm playing apex legends
I'm gonna be the champion
Guys, I'm gonna be the best. I'm already the best. You guys don't even need to tell me about it. I already know
All right, just a few more to mop up. Let me heal
It's like every like every like sixth shot or so it'll splay off into the distance I have no idea
Why one more let me do a sweet 360 no-scope on this one
*grunting noises*
You see that it's pretty good right? No, right we Casey died. I'm so sad about that apparently
Alright, I guess we gotta get home I think
Unless we can go here. Oh
That's fine. I'll kill all units to win the battle easy
I wish there was something or I hope there's something that's like a persistent base that you got to build up back home
because that would be cool like
Oh
Do you want to enter blockchainZ's storage? Yeah
Yeah, I do. Yeah Wow
Alright, I only have two people left with me. I don't know how good this is gonna go for me, but sure. Yeah, okay
Let's do this
Probably not the best idea is just to run out into the open. Oh Jeez-ums. Can I jump over this?
Can I jump on this? Can I please just jump on this I just oh
my god
There we go. I jumped
Yeah, take some of that one of these some of this this is working out real good for me one down
tango Down
Alright moving up for better cover
Never mind. How about one of these? Hoopie
All right. Let me get closer for a Kobe. Kobe! Oh shit. I'm gonna die. I'm gonna die. Heal. heal damn it
Nice, like it weren't no thing it's like someone using a full heal in in uh in Pokemon
This is really cheap and cheesy and just makes you feel real shit, but it's me doing it. So I feel great.
I don't know what that guy was shooting at but that was dumb. Anyway, I got the level 4, I lost TJ not TJ
No not oh shit. Oh
Well, hmm that that don't seem good
That don't seem good. I should probably be home. Well
That ain't good. Um
Go to battle. Alright, this is yeah, this is what I was hoping for. Ok
Why don't I have more people with me? I felt like I had more people before
All right, whatever. Let's go for it. Whoa, I got more people
Where did y'all come from?
Okay. All right, then. Thank you. Thank you for it here. Follow me
Wait, wait fuck do they follow me or?
Select all platoons, uh here follow. No? just you. Just just you, okay
That's a little bizzare but alright
What are you shooting at? That building piss you off?
You'll get him eventually. If you shoot keep shooting enough, you'll get through the building and eventually you'll hit your target
So just keep keep keep at it. Oh, that's a lot, but I got grenades
Watch this
Kobe
LeBron
Wow
Wow you guys suck wow you guys suck
Wow you guys suck. Ooh, you're terrible Ooh
Y'all suck
No, no, no, no, I don't even need this site down
Oh you suck. I'm the best!
Alright, so it's a little on - ally casualties? How did they die?
What? what did they just fall over themselves? Well, that's not fair. Alright, whatever. I guess.
not exactly perfect right now but
This is a lot of potential I could see this being a really cool game the game design
Aspect of it like the the idea behind it. I really like
Group of enemies? Try to flee. I failed to flee. Okay. Well, I guess let's just see what happens when I die
Oh come at me you Bastards, come at me. See look. I got a bajillion people over there
*uninteligible scream*
Ooh fuck
All right, well that was fun, but anyway that it's pretty good I got to I can't lie that is not bad
That is kind of fun if they had some more refinement to it
Like the gunplay was a little better the the actual building was more important like the zombies were a bit smarter in the AI
There's a lot of room here to grow so project blockchain Z is what it's called not
Bad not bad at all. So that was three awesome games
Thank you everybody so much for watching if you want to play these games for yourself
I'll provide a link in the description
and if you've got other cool short
Indie games that you want me to play put them down in the comments and check out the huge
Playlist of awesome games that I've made link is in the description as well. Thanks again
And as always, I will see you in the next video. Bye. Bye
*ending music*